j'arrive dans un adresse dans les bras
d'un dragon bleu qui me porte dans l'air
qui m'amène sous la mer non non non j'en
étais drogue tu voudrais en parler
rien du tout ça c'est les années canal
hein
bonsoir bonsoir ça va merci
le travail d'abord après on va se
détendre boire des verres oui bien sûr
on va faire une after
et là sérieux
surtout que Chantal est la double promo
double bonsoir on coupera
niaque qui est une autobiographie et
puis le CD et le DVD
donc il réclame
[Applaudissements]
alors si on écoute bien écoutez
tu peux deviner ce qu'il a envie de
manger rien qu'au fond de son rire pour
moi c'est du poisson qui réclame
[Musique]
alors le CD donc c'est un best of et le
DVD c'est le spectacle mystérieux voyage
de Marie-Rose c'est quoi le pitch c'est
un petit garçon qui est une histoire
vraie qui m'est arrivé quand il était
pensionnaire qui est tombé dans dans une
dans un lac glacé et évidemment ce petit
garçon ben moi je suis celle qui va le
retrouver et je me bats contre les
quatre éléments du monde la terre le feu
l'eau et l'air avec des enfants alors la
terre on va sous la terre on rencontre
des rats pour toi mais tu vas t'y faire
ah oui c'est vrai
le royaume des pâquerettes
c'est bisounours
dans les bras d'un dragon bleu qui me
porte dans l'air qui m'amène sous la mer
[Rires]
il y a
Serge il est chiant il veut que vous le
fassiez avec les oreilles de lapin
est-ce que les enfants vont toujours
vers vous naturellement
de police qui m'arrêtait qui m'a dit
alors je dis ça y est j'ai dit qu'est-ce
que j'ai encore fait oh là là bon ça
commence et il m'a dit non non je vais
vous demander qu'une chose c'est parce
que moi je vous ai tellement aimé petite
quand j'avais 3 ans est-ce que vous
pouvez me chanter le lapin alors moi
j'ai ouvert la fenêtre j'ai fait ce
matin un lapin est-ce que vous le
chanter à ma femme avec le portable
alors j'ai chanté dans le portable il
m'a dit écoutez chaque fois que je serai
là je vous le demanderai parce que je
vous aime trop non c'est tous les grands
c'est leur maman et leur papa parce que
c'est génération
1980 à son Goya comme on l'appelle petit
vous demande comment on fait des enfants
vous répondez quoi
c'est un petit non c'est un petit de 8
ans vous demande comment on fait des
enfants vous dites pas avec la [ __ ]
j'imagine dans un chou avec la vie mais
dans un chou ah ouais pour 8 ans vous
dites quoi le chanteur vous dites tu vas
avoir tuto tu as un petit fiancé que tu
adores et puis mais c'est compliqué ce
que vous me demandez là
de parents vous savez bien ils ont tous
des missionné les parents de depuis mes
68 Chantal avec une partie de notre
corps qui est ah bah voilà
qui vont voilà
tout simplement et puis c'est très
agréable et puis ça se passe très bien
ce sera pas bien
c'est pas une belle affiche pour le
Palais des Congrès
des chansons petit quand les enfants
vous demandent quand les enfants vous
demandent pourquoi c'est pas bien la
drogue vous dites quoi
les gens vont pas vous croire ils vont
aller en prendre quand même donc quand
on dit que c'est de la merde on a du mal
à dire à croire que c'est de la merde
avec tout le monde en prenne les gens
croient pas surtout à 70 € le gramme
quoi
je n'ai jamais pris je suis même pas une
cigarette j'ai jamais pris jamais
d'alcool quand mettons un petit enfant
vous dit maman pourquoi vous dit
pourquoi j'ai le zizi tout dur vous
dites quoi mettons vous
est-ce que Bécassine elle aime lapine
c'est la question que beaucoup de gens
se posent chez eux vraiment c'était une
vraie question
oui ou non
c'était le DVD le CD Laurent maintenant
on va passer au livre s'appelle laniaque
hein chez Jacques Marie Lafont éditeur
alors là on comprend mieux le personnage
de Chantal Goya votre côté un peu enfant
attardé parce que finalement enlève
enfant
adorer
laissez-moi finir parce que après il y
avait après il y avait l'explication
c'était pas juste
non mais Thierry je te rappelle que
Chantal a peur elle a le trac il faut
l'aider
bisous
et bien voilà
tu vas la pécho
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a pas de posture
on comprend mieux le personnage de
Chantal Goya un peu enfant attardé quand
on sait que vous avez eu une prime
enfance en Indochine à l'époque
coloniale c'est ce qu'on apprend en
lisant le livre et que vous avez gardé
de cette époque des souvenirs magiques
période très heureuse près de Saigon les
vacances dans les montagnes à Dallas au
Cambodge etc donc voilà ce que je
voulais dire et et le père le père de
Chantal dirigeait une plantation d'hévéa
de 40 000 hectares il a été obligé de
fuir le pays ça a été l'exode vous êtes
retrouvé en métropole après un voyage
épouvantable et là vous vous retrouvez à
Paris dans un minuscule appartement de
50 ans avec des grands-parents
insupportables voilà et vous recréer
votre enfance en Indochine voilà ce que
je voulais dire c'est à dire que
c'est vrai vous avez toute votre vie
cherché à retrouver cette prime enfance
indochinoise avec avec les pousse-pousse
avec les grands arbres
j'avais une chinoise qui s'occupait de
moi qui est une Assane qui est une femme
sacrée qui a dû me donner quelque chose
d'important parce que mes frères et
soeurs ont pas un petit peu cette espèce
de tonus que j'ai et j'ai traversé
toutes les difficultés toujours avec
optimisme laniac mais c'est vrai que
déjà toute petite j'ai traversé des
difficultés sans même me rendre compte
par exemple quand il y avait les
Japonais qui étaient au pied de la
maison et qui voulaient assassiner qui
ont assassiné beaucoup de Français moi
j'étais caché dans un dans un dans un
sous un lit je crois oui mon frère était
dans un placard et moi évidemment quand
maman regardait à travers les volets ce
qui se passait parce que les Vietnamiens
nous aimaient beaucoup et nous aidaient
moi je traversais la maison j'ai
descendu l'escalier j'ai demandé à
l'armée de me lasser mon là c'est de
chaussures et alors ils ont
et puis ils sont partis et la famille
était sauvée alors deuxième choc de
votre vie votre rencontre avec les
Beatles
à l'époque vous sortez avec le fils du
duc et la duchesse de Bedford
vous aviez même pas que c'est le fils du
dieu que la duchesse
à Paris l'après-midi c'était soirée de
l'après-midi moi je fais opposé pas de
questions qu'est-ce que fait ton père ta
mère et quand j'étais à Londres et que
j'étais au père il m'a dit je
t'emmènerai chez mes parents en week-end
ou en vacances ou déjeuner je sais plus
déjeuner alors elle est venue je me suis
rhabillée pour enlever tous mes tabliers
et autres et puis je savais pas où
j'étais tombé j'en croyais pas mes yeux
et ils m'ont dit à déjeuner il y aura
des gens importants qui viendront
et dans la grande salade
avec les frères
[Rires]
personnages qui sont arrivés et là j'ai
halluciné c'était les Beatles
et alors le choc suivant ça a été votre
rencontre avec Jean-Jacques Debout là ça
a été love à te faire ça et c'est à dire
que à peine il vous a vu il vous dit
j'ai l'impression de vous connaître
depuis toujours on se là on aura deux
enfants vous serez célèbre à 30 ans et
vous chanterez à l'opéra en attendant on
va baiser
[Rires]
alors je lui ai dit
on se mariera peut-être chanter
certainement pas parce que je suis pas
vraiment une voix de alors quand à
l'Opéra si j'étais Maria Callas ça
serait et avoir deux enfants bon ça peut
être possible et ben voilà et tout ce
qui est arrivé est arrivé il vous
propose de le suivre en type parce qu'il
allait participer à la rose d'or avec
cette génial chanson qui s'appelle nos
doigts se sont croisés et ils vous
oublie à Paris
vous le rencontrez et vous promet de
vous épouser de vous faire deux enfants
il vous invite à Antibes et il part sans
vous ça aurait dû vous servir de leçon
je crois que vous ayez persévéré au-delà
de cela moi c'est tout ce qui
m'intéresse
qui m'intéresse et que je vais aller
plus loin
ça y est je regarde pas servi de Me pas
du tout vous êtes obligés d'y aller avec
quelqu'un d'autre finalement comme je
suis ben non parce que j'avais dit
j'avais fait un gros mensonge à mes
parents je leur avais dit que je partais
un weekend chez votre copine donc mon
père m'a dit je revois quand même ce que
tu as dans ton sac alors j'ai montré un
jean de tennis et après je peux plus
rentrer parce que j'avais non je pouvais
pas j'ai dit il faut que j'y aille et
puis j'aime beaucoup et la gagner alors
il avait arraché le chèque au maire il y
avait un chèque de 10000 francs et
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait elle a acheté une
maison
une fois il a acheté un bateau avec un
chèque de 200 francs il avait rajouté
3-0 c'est vrai ou pas
et vous mettez à la maison
je sais pas quoi il allait au Salon
Nautique bon je peux même pas attention
moi je reviens le soir à genre minuit
et je vois dans mon salon Tabarly et
petit pas Eric petit pas
bon ils étaient tous là autour d'un
grand enfin d'un énorme plan de bateau
je dis qu'est-ce que c'est que tout ça
il me dit ah ben oui j'ai annoncé une
bonne nouvelle ça y est j'ai acheté un
très beau bateau leptide qui est qui
avait été construit par John Alden je
dis mais comment on va faire et il me
dit bah oui non mais on s'arrangera et
tout oh là là j'ai appelé les ateliers
de la Trinité c'était pas là j'ai appelé
tous les chantiers de de Hollande et
c'était là et là j'étais prendre un
train j'étais chercher mon chèque et
puis le bateau
il achète un bateau donc à 19 ans vous
installez avec lui et au bout d'un
moment vous avez envie de faire du
journalisme vous allez voir Daniel
Philippe Pâquis en lui disant je veux
travailler dans la presse et lui vous
propose de chanter des chansons de
Jean-Jacques Debout c'est bien Bernard
le plus vénère de la mort et Daniel l'a
mis sur salut les copains et puis
voilà j'étais affolé et là alors pire
que tout vous tournez avec Jean-Luc
Godard qui vous demande de de vous
déshabiller c'est pour masculin féminin
et vous refusez de vous mettre toute nue
pourquoi vous avez
enceinte de mon fils et je voulais pas
le dire bon ça a commencé bien et on
n'était pas marié j'ai su vraiment
j'étais enceinte de 3 mois et j'ai dit à
Marlène comment je peux faire Marlène
Jobert comment je peux faire je veux pas
d'abord je veux pas me [ __ ] à poil ça
je veux pas elle me dit t'inquiète pas
tu vas te cacher sous le lavabo et moi
je vais passer une fois et deux fois je
fais passer en faisant ton des gestes à
toi et puis moi je vais passer à ma
façon je dis OK et moi j'étais planqué
sous lavabo puis Godard a dit mais c'est
bizarre on dirait la même silhouette qui
passe il a ouvert la porte il m'a dit
mais dis donc tu te fiches de moi
qu'est-ce que tu fais là dessous je dis
bah moi je veux pas tourner à poil alors
je vais dire tu seras jamais une vedette
je dis je m'en fous la seule vedette que
je connais c'est ma machine à laver
alors du coup du coup
[Applaudissements]
et puis voilà non mais il y a aussi la
même chose
quand j'étais en Allemagne je devais
faire un très grand film et là je devais
tourner avec un vrai baiser avec un
garçon qui arrivait vu arriver à Mike
Brant du tout
j'espère que c'est pas celui-là et c'est
évidemment celui-là et elle va le baiser
c'est comme ça alors on m'a dit bon vous
virez terminez plus de film vous aimez
pas vous balader à poil embrasser les
garçons comment ça se fait réserve ça à
Jean-Jacques alors après bon ben c'est
l'époque des succès vous inventez avec
Jean-Jacques Debout le Music Hall pour
enfants c'est vous qui avez inventé ça
sera coupé au montage à quel âge tu as
baisé pour la première fois
ça suffit
[Musique]
alors le vendredi 13 décembre 1985 ça
porte malheur déjà Patrick Sabatier vous
reçoit dans le jeu de la vérité vous
appellerez cette émission un meurtre en
direct et ce n'est que 8 ans plus tard
que vous pouvez regarder la cassette de
l'émission
et vous dites j'ai vu une folle qui
parle
moi d'abord j'avais pas voulu la faire
ce que j'étais en plein spectacle du
mystérieux voyage de Marie-Rose que vous
avez vu et moi j'avais dit ça sert à
rien parce que c'est tellement archi
complet je me vois pas dans une émission
ou des adultes vont me parler donc ils
m'ont dit non ce seront des enfants qui
vont venir vous parler
à ce moment là j'ai douté un peu et
Jean-Jacques m'a dit il n'en est même
pas question Thierry Le Luron qui était
là m'a dit Chantal ils vont te malheur
te planter ça va être l'horreur et j'ai
dit ok je la fais plus donc j'ai appelé
j'ai dit on la fait plus et l'avant
veille le réalisateur m'a dit écoute on
a notre amitié tu devrais quand même la
faire ça sera magnifique il y aura des
belles choses on va voir Jean-Jacques je
ne voyais pas Jean-Jacques il ne veut
pas
finalement tout le monde a tellement
c'est moi qui est qui suis allé au
charbon en fin de compte alors j'ai joué
mon spectacle et la veille Jean-Jacques
m'a dit tu vois c'est bien on a toutes
les lignes de journaux mais je peux te
dire qu'à 10h40 il y aura plus de
Chantal Goya
et je me suis retrouvé avec ma robe rose
de Marie Rose devant mon décor avec
l'arbre la forêt et tout ayant joué
l'après-midi à 8h30 le même public
devant moi de 12000 personnes et pas une
question d'enfant et moi chaque fois
j'étais je prenais tout au troisième
degré alors quand est-ce que vous partez
la chirurgie à la chirurgie esthétique
avec votre tronche d'autres c'est pas
grave on verra un jour et puis toute
manière
si voilà ce qui s'est passé c'est que
c'est qu'en fait vous croyez vous
adressez aux enfants en leur faisant des
grimaces en disant je vais mettre les
enfants dans ma poche je vais leur faire
des grimaces et le réalisateur Rémi
grand bac lui il montre pas les les gens
ont eu l'idée de mettre une fausse
institutrice
c'est elle qui a tout déclenché c'est
pas avant avant je m'en sortais très
bien ça se passait bien et cette fausse
institutrice quand je vais demander de
quelle classe vous êtes elle a jamais pu
me le dire c'était j'ai dit bon alors
c'est fini je suis dans un traquenard
alors là maintenant j'ai dit à sabète
j'ai dit à cette femme bah écoutez vous
m'aimez pas changer de chaîne j'allais
pas dire madame vous êtes je suis une
conne et je vous remercie ça c'est pas
possible devant plus tout mon public
puis j'aime pas dire ça j'en ai même pas
question alors j'ai dit bon ben je pose
mon micro j'ai dit à Patrick moi je suis
désolé il y a Simone Signoret sur la 2
c'est beaucoup mieux que Chantal Goya je
m'adresse à mon public qui sont les
enfants et je chantais le pain et là
j'ai posé mon micro j'avais tous ces
gosses devant moi qu'on ne montrait
jamais voilà
parce que dans la panique j'ai une
espèce d'attaque de panique de terrorisé
et je me suis réfugiée dans le monde de
l'enfance parce que j'étais mariée rose
et l'image elle a été changée et moi
j'ai vu quand je suis sortie de là j'ai
toujours pas compris à la fin de
l'émission parce que tout le monde était
dans la salle à crier Chantal Chantal et
quand je suis sortie que j'ai vu
ça aide honneur de tous mes techniciens
qui étaient pratiquement en larmes vous
êtes arrivés dans la régie et là vous
vous tombez sur Jean-Jacques debbouivre
mort
tout ça il avait il avait vu il avait
senti c'était quelqu'un qui avait tout
compris bien avant tout le monde et
étant donné qu'il est quand même la
personne qui m'aime le plus et qui était
proche de moi il était malheureux et
finalement on a mis 100 personnes au
chômage et c'est pour ça que moi comme
je suis ça m'a pas cassé moi parce que
moi j'étais vrai vis-à-vis de mon public
quand j'ai fait le lapin et que j'ai dit
changer de changer de chaîne avec
Chantal Goya c'est que vous m'aimez pas
c'était pour sauver tout le public des
petits qui m'aimaient et être proche
d'eux une véritable volonté de nuire
derrière cette histoire Chantal
attendez
qui aurait eu envie de vous nuire
moi je pense que enfin j'ai pas encore
la réponse exacte mais je pense que
il y avait une grande jalousie qui
circulait dans enfin les gens étaient
assez jaloux de mon succès et il y a des
gens qui m’adoraient et des gens qui
m'aimaient pas c'est normal aujourd'hui
tout est bien qui finit bien car tu es
culte non mais je vais vous dire une
chose et tu es une histoire pour les
gosses tu es qu'une pour les adultes et
tu es hyper populaire donc ça se termine
bien tu as envie de faire un duo
je vais vous dire Thierry je vais vous
dire ça devait m'arriver cette histoire
et moi je l'ai très bien prise parce que
je me suis dit c'est peut-être très
triste tout ce qui vient de m'arriver
mais c'est un grand bonheur pour moi de
retrouver mes petits-enfants ma famille
enfin mes enfants qui étaient que je
voyais pas beaucoup ma famille mes amis
et d'être auprès du public qui me
réconfortait tous les jours dites-moi
vous lui diriez quoi aujourd'hui à
Patrick Sabatier s'il était là
j'ai jamais vu c'est qu'elle existe mais
qu'elle n'est pas si tu triste ça je le
sais que c'était quelqu'un qui était
payé par la production je suis toujours
demandé comment ça se fait qu'un
journaliste n'a pas été plus loin dans
cette histoire et n'a pas été voir qui
était cette femme qui peut-être est très
malheureuse dans son coin parce qu'elle
en a pris plein la tronche aussi autant
que moi parce qu'elle est pas si tu
triste aujourd'hui tout va bien mais le
lendemain des missions tout allait bien
une émission comme le jeu de la vérité
par exemple pour craquer plus on va voir
regardez-moi
vous pensez pas que votre spectacle est
nul à chier Chantal Goya non j'adore mon
spectacle j'aurais jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au bout
vous pensez pas que vous avez tissé les
enfants mais non j'ai pas ou si c'est
votre choix vous pensez pas qu'à votre
âge il faudrait les laisser tranquille
les enfants maintenant il y a pas d'âge
pour faire rêver ça marche
c'est bien durci c'est que j'ai gardé ma
sensibilité mais j'ai un bon paravent de
vent
alors il y a un truc extraordinaire dans
le bouquin je trouve c'est que vous
fermez les yeux sur les aventures de
Jean-Jacques Debout c'est vous vous
dites que vous l'avez jamais trompé non
jamais jamais parce que
j'ai jamais eu
mais non parce que le premier mec que je
rencontre je parle que de Jean-Jacques
alors il en a ras-le-bol vous êtes déjà
je préfère avoir des des moments tendres
en regardant quelqu'un qui m'attendrique
aller tout de suite dans un lit non ça
s'intéresse pas c'est terminé ça fait 40
ans que vous êtes avec eux
et c'est mon éternel fiancé je
n'arrêterai pas de le dire et puis je
suis pas quelqu'un de
ne pas votre nom
et que vous avez envie d'y croire
Thierry merci Alain c'est vrai non mais
moi Jean-Jacques je pense que notre
histoire a toujours duré parce que et du
rap parce que
j'ai toujours baissé sa liberté de sais
s'il aime bien sortir voir des copains
et lui et lui il rentre bourré il dit
bonjour madame c'est un renouveau
d'abord il vient jamais en tournée parce
qu'il n'aime pas voyager il a très peur
dans l'avion il est sans mal j'ai fait
tout plein j'ai fait le monde entier
que je me connais je deviendrai
championne de chistera ça m'est arrivé
clac clac et puis on fait une réunion
sommeil et puis chaque cas s'explique et
puis ça va pas aller je m'en vais mais
là ça fait 40 ans que ça dure il faut
bien que le corps exulte quand même
ça n'empêche pas que on peut très bien
s'adorer et faire comme tout le monde
hein
justement c'est ça qui est bien c'est
que comme on est souvent séparé on se
revoit et on s'adore d'accord parce que
on est tout le temps collé où vas-tu
on n'a jamais mis d'alliance
à l'antenne
l'alliance que j'avais c'était un rideau
un rideau de
vous servir de leçons
[Applaudissements]
Chantal Goya est-ce que vous vous êtes
déjà dit le prochain qui me parle du jeu
de la vérité je lui mets une grosse
patate je crois que le prochain je vais
le faire mais comment tu as vécu ce jeu
de la vérité
est-ce que vous êtes déjà dit si je
retrouve cette [ __ ] d'institutrice je
lui défonce la gueule est-ce que vous
êtes déjà dit bon j'aime pas les enfants
mais tant pis
est-ce que vous êtes déjà dit il boit
d'accord mais bon il fait de bonnes
chansons quand même il est pas
alcoolique Jean-Jacques il boit parce
qu'il aime le bon vin mais il boit
jamais le matin jamais à midi et si je
dîne avec lui le soir il boit pas
vous êtes déjà dit allez après tout mon
mec est en prison
[Rires]
vous êtes déjà dit non 5 dans un seul
lit c'est trop
puis ça fait quand même il y a pas de
mathématiques
non non mais c'est trop vous êtes déjà
dit chanteuse c'est peut-être pas mon
truc finalement
vous êtes déjà dit j'ai envie de mourir
là
oui je peux mourir mais ma grande anti
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de moi où
est-ce qu'on va faire ce matin ce matin
et c'était l'horreur vous êtes déjà dit
allez hop ma grosse origine oui oui
parce que il y a 3 ans j'ai essayé une
robe et la vendeuse elle m'a dit vous
inquiétez pas quand vous aurez fait
votre bébé ça ira Lara vous ira mieux je
dis mais non c'est mon bide alors
vous êtes déjà dit et si je me faisais
refaire les seins
vous êtes déjà dit [ __ ] mais qu'est-ce
que je fous Queen à 3h du matin avec
tous ces connards en train de chanter
papa ballon
mais des fois je me dis il est 4h du
matin et j'ai toujours pas chanté ils
sont tous comme des fous
n'est pas là je commence à m'endormir il
va falloir que ça va être catastrophique
et ben non j'ai la pêche et j'y vais à
32 ans ça vous fait pas flipper ça pas
du tout c'est moi c'est non ça veut dire
que je suis le repère de leur enfant
c'est ça me fait un beau cadeau et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu